wir haben erstmal hier pferde wir haben
hier drei pferde dann haben wir hier
pferde hier drei weiße pferde dann haben
wir da hinten wieder pferde dann haben
wir da hinten widerfährt einer nach oben
wieder pferde dann haben wir hier wieder
pferde
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren sieht vorstellung in der
minecraft 17.22 hat der zieht einen sehr
witzigen namen und zwar erstmal was der
zieht hat und zwar eine menge pferde
einfach pferde pferde pferde über pferde
da ist ein kleines tierchen meiner
softbox verpiss dich mensch sehr gut
förder ganze herde der sieht ist sie
zahlen also sieht sind wie frauen es
gibt richtig viele und fast keine sind
gut alter das habe ich ganz einfach so
der interpretiert also ich liebe alle
frauen erspart
nein doch also verpisst euch einfach
schnauze jetzt soll lassen wir das
landschaft wird generiert und wir kommen
hier raus moment auf schalte ich das im
survival gemacht euch penner
na gut wir haben erstmal hier pferde wir
haben hier 3 fährt dann haben wir hier
pferde haben wir drei weiße fehle dann
haben wir da hinten wieder pferde dann
haben wir da hinten wieder fährt nach
oben wie der pferde dann haben wir hier
wieder pferde als wenn ihr euch alle
pferde cent da könnt ihr sohn fetten
bauernhof aufmachen ihr würdet bei bauer
sucht frau einfach alle kriegen wenn ihr
alle pferde hättet das ist so heftig
mach das nochmal im dings modus imbaba
modus kreativ damit wir das noch mal
wenn ich euch das noch ein bisschen rum
fliegen zeigen kann
also das ist so krass ich habe noch nie
ich glaube ich habe noch nicht das man
ganz kurzen stück während das hier
generiert
schön kaltes wasser wartet kein geld für
aber das hier als glasflaschen matze
dass die glasflasche das ist das
allerbeste wasser gerolsteiner naturell
glasflasche wirklich glasflasche und an
kühl lagern dass das all das es gibt
ich krieg da nix für aber schmeckt
einfach im ganzen also wir haben 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21 19 22 23 in 15 26 27 28 19 30 1 3
233 34 35 36 36 da hinten haben
natürlich auch noch welche auch noch 137
38 39 40 41 42 43 40 50 46 47 48 49 50
51 52 53 54 55 56 57 58
da hinten waren oder welche 58 und war
gerade kommen 100 schaffen mache 80 59
60 61 62 63 64 wichtigsten schafe 64
wir sind hier gar nicht mehr so gar
nicht ob du das ist ja gar nichts ist so
krank wie viele fälle sind da haben wir
ganz viele kleine dann haben wir hier
immens viele hier sind wieder ein paar
boxen ich finde diese sounds so traurig
wenn man fertig dass es so kommen
das ist so richtig mit basteln das hört
sich an als wenn man ihnen das buch
gemacht
auch diese kleinen schon die kleinen
sind nervig aber so die mutter bekommen
weiß nicht ich mich mag das nicht wenn
man pferde boxt weiß ich nicht kann ich
nicht ab ich könnte nie ein pferd
schlagen hier sind panik affäre
hallo ich boxen ich bin kein rassist war
nur spaß
aber hier sind so krass wie die pferde
direkt am 2 ohne [ __ ] ausschluss bin
man nimmt sich einfach
im gras mit und dann schnüffeln die
einfach an dem gras und werden direkt
high und wir lieben euch
nein dann holt ihr euch ein bisschen
weiß macht welch ein paar brote und er
gibt ihr den das recht ob weizen recht
auch schon aber wir sind einfach so
viele ferne das ist so krass heftig na
ja weil sonst so von wegen keine
landschaften aber guckt euch das einfach
anders ist mega krass wenn es euch
gefallen hat gibt den daumen nach oben
wollten es die vorstellung schreibt
seine kommentare und dann würde ich
sagen alter das ist okay vielleicht auch
noch ein paar geile landschaften ich
liege ja mal ganz schön ist auch egal
könnte selbst rausfinden